this video is brought to you by expressvpn
and Shopify people more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation hello my
name is Aaron today and I'm here with the one
the only Mister Andrew flash cor but it doesn't
matter what my name is what matters is who's in
this film and that is the rock sorry I had to get
that out it's the wrestling fan in me it's okay
I'm a wrestling fan at heart too this is going
to be Rampage beer watching today starring what
he said the one the only Mr Dwayne The Rock
Johnson you guys leave a like on this video
subscribe hit that notification Bell thank
you so much to prepper for helping us edit
down these highlights fulllength Reaction watch
alongs where you can sync up with your own copy
available for you super sexy rejects or over on
patreon Greg and John cover several shows over
there with exclusive highlights and watch alongs
included for you I like Dwayne The Rock Johnson
he likes Dwayne The Rock Johnson so we're going
to see what this movie's all about y'all are you
guys ready are you ready I'm ready I'm so ready
I'm going to raise my eyebrow I don't know how to
raise my eyebrow you got to practice in the mirror
just eyebrow raises all right we're ready to get
rampaged yeah my only experience with this I
did play the video game just a couple times
from my recollection the N64 game but it was so
long ago I almost don't remember I just remember
destroying some buildings yeah I remember seeing
the boxes like wow it was like a fun [Music]
game this is control we have negative copy
on that last transmission we are sh in the
command mod oh no Miss control this is
Atkins the crew is dead reroute to the
lab and secure the canisters before departure
but the test subject is loose the test subject
is a wrap not anymore whoa W what a way
to start a movie just suck you right in
what is this you have your orders doctor
open the goddamn door Dr Atkins it's CLA
widen we'll unlock the escape capsule
when you secure the samples that's cold
either you come home with my research or
you don't come home at all damn wow was
so messed up I know but she's got to go in
there and deal with priorities am I right
however big the rat is that we saw in that
half a second it passed the camera take it
down
oh is that a hand just
floating Mission Control securing the
samples now copy that I hope she quits
after this got to slap them first and
then quit if she's able to survive this
right that's priority number one get that
that clean slap in warning integ critical
oh ooh
Dam what the what the porcupine
rat nope nope nope one no part of that no
thank you he's going to break he's going
to break in no hope not oh good escape with
her though I hope not that' be really sad
almost had some alien Vibes to it like it
Andrew who's that actress believe that's
Marley Shelton who's in The Sandlot scream
four scream five this is why he's here he
knows he's oh no oh no oh chick burning up
on re-entry oh but the the samples survived
though I know that bald head love that smell
brings me right back to Uganda Huey oh there we
go we got Jack qua is in this what two scream Five
actors in This film apparently now oh wow they
call me L Diablo I know they don't speak Spanish
but they might as well you ever see a blood
diamond yeah no I know it's about diamonds but it
really captures the vibe don't mess with Mother
Africa you know what I'm another actor from the
boys too the director everything okay boss no it's
not don't move a muscle junior Here is dropping
a lot of monkey [__] get with these madeup
stories I love the way he delivered that
line regardless if you had any experience
with poaching you would know that it's extremely
rude to talk about it in front of a lady it's okay
I can handle it well I know you can I'm talking
about these ladies is this the sequel to Jumanji
Welcome to the Jungle it feels I me pretty much
could be wow Andrew this is the second movie We're
watching together that involves monkey SL primat
oh right right 28 Days Later right yeah tell me
what do you see the young male is attempting
to establish his presence with the female he's
posturing agitated sounds like someone we
know right Pabo Pabo it's okay FEI enu on
station come it's me no that means
rock that does not mean it's me good
boy so that means rock rock of course
it means rock look at who's saying it
well yeah I guess that's it is true it's me
he's the rock so I guess that's that's meta
I mean it makes sense if you move we're going
to be in big trouble Connor do not move Conor
do what he says uhoh uhoh he's going to
freak out he's going to freak out no help
help oh oh protected
him y buo one Connor Connor it's
okay George George George of the
Jungle uhuh oh very funny very funny you and
I laughing at your joke okay new guy he no
laugh he cried yeah he looks so good it's
okay it's okay it's okay he's not going to
kill me no he's not going to kill you he
has a unique sense of humor I could it's
a good thing he's wearing the brown pants
it's important for you to be nice to Pavo
he's just a kid a poachers killed his
entire family he's in your troop now I
want you to welcome him welcome Pavo welcome
Pavo George you and I cool probably did that
wrong I should never have taught you that stop
that now come on now get did you got to teach
him the eyebrow raise that'd be extra impressive
I need you to protect Papa family family like is
this the right franchise I thought The Rock was
already in that franchise it's the spin-off ah
it's a really good good looking ape though
yeah for sure the effects are great that was
amazing thank you and I would love to learn more
about those submission techniques if you have
time for a drink I'm sure I'm sure she would jez
that's a subtext with the LI bite and everything
subtext for I want some right she used the
word submission that's a clue it's a blues
clue is that the space or
I would imagine that was the
ship with the samples or I could do my comic
book reference and say it's
venom venom [Applause] [Music]
venom very good I visually visually speaking
it does look kind of you know look Phenom no
kind of yeah oh George be careful buddy oh got
that spray on him got spritzed with the alien
spr oh yeah we saw that rat he was definitely a
lot bigger and filer looking take your message
about George you okay I don't know what do you
mean I don't know Davis he's in the grizzly
enclosure the grizzly en closure cuz that boy
got big Jesus we killed the a bear oh my God
jeez do we know who would win a fight between
a bear and a gorilla well yeah and also too
we saw like the rat was going crazy I was going
to say going ape [__] what happened I went on
rampage oh my God George it looks bigger
right he a lot bigger yeah is it me or is
he considerably bigger okay that was
my reaction yeah I know he's huge he
was like way down yeah before what the
hell happened we were doing our morning
rounds when we saw the burnt foliage and
uh wonder how many other animals were
infected what is it we got to figure it out
station you done we just lost billions of
dollars Claire funny I was just singing a
song from Watchmen and here's is Molen Akerman or
whatever her name is a got the research samples
onto the Escape pod canisters were engineered
to withstand re-entry and the American meteor
Society just reported a meteor strike in Southern
Wyoming all we have to do is go get it back they
seem like warm-hearted people that care about a
lot oh yeah they're they're real charity cases
there's a reason we were doing these experiments
in space and it wasn't exactly for the betterment
of humanity what I'm Sor oh did you see that the
Rampage video game ah it's very meta remember that
private military firm we acquired last year
that's so called them Killers or us yeah well
he's the US it kind of reminds me of everyone's
favorite video game movie Double Dragon where
they had did you ever see that one years ago
maybe uh they actually had the video game of
double dragon in the film towards the end of the
film oh really it's like this is really meta ien
having your own arcade game in the movie itself
I love it oh yeah they'd have to make some direct
reference to it even if it is in the backgound
it's a fun Easter egg Hey Joe Magano don't you
mean death stroke we got to get my I got to get
my com oh the Deathstroke that never happened well
he had one appearance he had Justice League
or I guess I could call him Flash Thompson
Spider-Man are we going to see Deathstroke
versus Black Adam right now oh right there you
go [__] another Naomi Harris film we're doing
what I know I've already been late twice this
week but it will not happen again wow so we got
monkeys and Naomi haris that's our bread and
butter right there these were Brave and Brilliant
men and women of science were committed to helping
Mankind and we will continue that work in their
honor that's enough thank you helping mankind
my ass yeah that's what we said dramatic video
of a fireball touching down near the San Diego
Wildlife Sanctuary however it's unclear if this
is related to one of the parks gorillas escaping
the enclosure at the sanctuary earlier rear
gorilla escapes hold on a second Mark the car
ahead of me it just uh exploded what yep that was
a good improv smooth I'm sure buy it I mean it can
happen you know it happens you know oh I'm sure
we'll find out more about that no last time no
further contact we should C the canister but it
was pretty badly damaged whatever was in it was
destroyed there's something else these wolves were
slaughtered looks like another one killed the pack
it's infected with a pathogen Burke I need that
wolf Dead or Alive a super wolf is that a Robocop
reference he killed a grizzly bear okay he snapped
his neck like it was a toothpick listen protocol
says first sign of aggression mandates immediate
isolation it's what we're doing look at him I'm
looking at him really look at him he's in pain
all right everybody listen up I need to find some
someone who knows exactly what the hell this thing
is I found her y I'm a geneticist with enene you
recovered my research sample yeah you mean this
please tell me you have that tested for residual
particulates I always do that anytime something
new comes in Amy have this tested for residual
particules what the hell is that thing doing
to my friend uh well I am not at Liberty he's
growing isn't he at an unprecedented rate right
demonstrating levels of aggression you don't see
in his species come with me if you want to live
last night he was 7t 500 lb this morning he's
almost 9 ft pushing 1,000 jeez yeah he's not B now
as far as I know he's the only living gorilla of
his kind he he can sign yeah he can sign and
he's hungry guys let's get George something
to eat I mean that much weight he's going to need
a lot more food now oh yeah are you familiar with
crisper it's more like genetic editing sharks are
indeterminate grows isolate that Gene and combine
it with say the growth of weight of a blue whale
the strength of a rhinocerous beetle you get one
confused gorilla that could take down jeez that
just sounds like a bad idea I mean it sounds like
a good idea for a movie but a bad idea for real
life yeah splicing I am the only one who can cure
them I don't know how much longer that place is
going to hold him no I'm going guess
about 2.5 more seconds yeah if that
everybody back well yeah she did say it makes him
more aggressive this is true she
didn't warn you George stop George
Davis call
911 oh the dog's barking hit him oh special
edition King Kong let's go okay yes I know you're
scared I'm going to help you W I always said that
manant stop I'm the primatologist here I look
after this animal it's okay come good stand down
don't worry buddy I'm going to help you oh it's
just going to make him aggressive hearing that
noise oh yeah it's the mercenaries mhm they going
to shoot him he's going to jump at the hel the
helicopter don't do that don't do that guys oh no
he's slowing him down a tranquilizer it actually
worked I'm [Music] surprised yeah but George is
smart as hell so when he does come to eventually
is he going to trust the rock anymore even though
the rock had nothing to do with the tranquilizing
maybe I think the Rock's going to be the only
thing that keeps him anchored to like who he is
you think George is going to die or you think
he's going to go back little being little I hope
not but I mean see oh my God that w is [Music]
Wolf I don't think that was a Tran rage one is
down say Rampage one is down I think that's what
he said that was quite a shot too that speed
that's not an easy target to hit when you're
in the helicopter and that the moving Target
like that what do you got nothing yet wait you
asked me if George is going to survive I don't
see those two surviving probably not depends
on how much of a dick he is I I see these two
being taken out in the building oh those two
are going to die I thought you're talking about
Joe magello no I I at those two in a building I
see them being taken out oh yeah no they're
they're garbage people they're going to die
boss damn it you don't get scared [Laughter]
what they're in a hurry I wonder
why God oh my God that's a super
super beast are you hunting it
or is it hunting you what the
hell I like that they're showing the cameras
are being taken out whoa come on get it they
won't pathogen is ding what we designed
it to Y maybe you should have kept it in
space get money that literally was a video game
shot right there first person shooter yeah I
can see that first person shooter Dwayne Johnson
appears in the Doom adaptation which features a
firstperson shooter sequence Easter egg Taylor
Taylor's dead buddy I'm sorry you should have
stayed on the helicopter didn't you watch didn't
you watch Predator one clearly this guy did not
he has a death wish or I guess Predator
sorry singular now where is that wolf damn
damn isn't this PG-13 I'm surprised they're
showing some of this stuff so I believe it
is oh it has like the spikes kind of how
the rat had the spikes that's right oh I
wonder how long that rat had been infect
I take it not ah cuz I guess the the
size transformation is relative to the animal
itself right well that that I'm sure that oh my
god oh okay I guess I stand yo oh my god oh my
god dude slicing it with the the yo that's crazy
damn that didn't even affect it getting sliced by
the the dude got that uh that super healing okay
I guess I stand corrected you should not have
stayed on the helicopter don't do that that's
how you survived buddy oh no oh God later bro I
think he's accepted his re reality or his fate
rather he can make it he's going to be fine he
be fine yeah oh my God I thought he's Joe Melo
that's Joe sorry we we don't get to see uh
Black Adam versus I thought he was going to
survive longer than that Deathstroke in this
I did too oh rip rip Deathstroke I definitely
thought he was going to survive longer than that
too at least for the rampaging portion of when
buildings are being taken out and all that well
I think also too it just drives uh the stakes
up and shows like nobody is possibly safe but
even though he's not I don't know if you would
call him the main character cuz we literally
just met him like about seven eight minutes
ago but big actor I guess big actor yeah know
that's a great way to establish Stakes though
yeah jeine Morgan hey it's Negan Thomas Wayne
sorry guys I had to hell of a day huh science
experiments falling from the sky giant Grill on
the loose just a kind of excitement [__] we
here at the government tend to notice feel like
he just came off the set of Walking Dead still
got that Negan ISM in him I said I want to see
George or we can get in each other's faces and
see who's the toughest brother I'm going to go
PR myself right out on the limb and guess if no
one's ever accused you of being a people person
I'll see you on board load him up with your
a uh is that going to be able a hold him for a
little bit goes again Davis SEO primate specialist
Army Special Forces but what are you some kind
of international Man of Mystery I see a lot he's
Austin Powers let cut the [__] Russell I
told you having George on this airplane is
he's on a very powerful sedative drip he will
not wake up until we wake him up I doubt that
at his rate of growth that sedative is going to
become ineffective long before we're back on the
ground we factored in his growth rate same as his
elevated metabolism and the increased amount of
blood in his system we're doing all right that's
not a government official gun you see his gun
right there that's like his own personal one yeah
has nice shiny belt buckle too yeah weirdos on the
internet calling him Ralph who do you work for
well sir I work for the American people land CIA
I think that's a reference to the game ohal it's
called Ralph again I I played the game so long ago
for a coup just a couple times so I don't I don't
remember all the Easter eggs and references just
remember destroying some stuff okay she helped
engineer the pathogen that infected George she
works for enery you mean used to she a rebel
Dr Kate cwell recruited by enene in 2010 fired
by enene a little less than two years ago why
caught trying to steal company hard drives and
did 13 what I'm sure were glorious months in
our beautiful Greenville Federal Correctional
Institute dang she's in jail I am guessing by the
look on the big Fell's face that this is all news
to him I really haven't even known each other
that long so it's not like this big betrayal
or anything that's a good point it's not like he
got to know her or anything right they met in like
the last scene George broke out and then they got
she was just there to help and explain what was
happening to George and not like sorry I lied
to you I mean did you you don't know this dude
can you cure George or not that's really what you
were there for he feels so betrayed he's so hurt
I know that enene was working on a countermeasure
to the no I mean they were her samples at the end
of the day so it wasn't like a total lie like
there's a scene missing between the last thing
we saw maybe maybe there was yeah maybe there
might be some delet a deleted scene or something
Kate Caldwell what is she doing out there given
our history with her her blaming us for putting
her in prison in the death of her brother okay so
that's her brother I figured it was not her man
she was going to get with The Rock that's why
she I would imagine going to company sabotage
blames them if you have a plan I would love to
hear it I always have a plan all right they're
they're awful people but it's comically hysterical
how how bad they are so it's like I don't mind it
yeah there's like they're cartoon villains yeah
exactly I don't in this type of film it doesn't
it doesn't bother me I actually appreciate it yeah
one small dose will stop an infected creature's
growth and aggression and to draw them here the
pathogen also genetically rewired the subject to
respond to a low frequency radio wave lucky for
us this building has some of the most powerful
radio antennas in the [Music] world ooh turn on
the signal and those creatures will do anything
to get here and make it stop are we going to get a
sky beam do you remember for like a good six-year
period where like every movie had the sky beam
I think this happened within that six is it yeah
probably I mean just off the the top of my head
I'm thinking Avengers Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
the Michael Bay one produced one I there was
so many movies that did it tasm one oh right
right yeah Amazing Spider-Man [Music] yes man
you getting all up in that is that is that the
W oh my God Ralph get Ralph Ralphie what oh this
this was the one that was in the water that was
affected what the hell is that what is it
[Music] Godzilla damn it's fast like that
they hit it though that's cool gives it
like a Jaws type of uh suspense yeah oh
is he going to hear it from up there I feel
like he's going to stay like relatively this
size till the the third act then he's going
to get like super big out of nowhere oh I
standing corrected he's going to get big
now oh he's hearing that noise damn is is
the plane going down it's going down down
in an earlier round oh crap oh oh no oh
boy oh George like to smash oh smash
damn they dead they're definitely
dead well yeah he can heal though so I don't
think those are going to really affect him much
yeah he'll be fine come on let's drop in oh oh y
see how strong I am let me just rip this all right
you have to be thrown into two situation ow either
this or Snakes on a Plane which one do you choose
I'm still probably choosing this one even though
I'd prefer to be neither I'm going pick this one
cuz he's not explicitly going after anybody he's
just like kind of freaking out I feel like if I'm
in the front of the plane he wouldn't get me feel
like it'd be fine I would just stand by the oh
God George put the government agent down well I
mean he is down leave him alone George now why
would you do that why would you do that he's going
to get you buddy he's going to rip you to [Music]
shreds oh [__] oh damn uh time to parachute
out of there y would all get suck out of there so
fast is George stuck on something
or is he holding on I can't
tell oh he's stuck on something oh
get o that's kind of hurt for
a little bit hang on tight
this is a thing we're going to die with that
attitude be more positive negative it's perfect
sync what about George save your
Boy George is like the Betrayal how dare you how
dare you do this to me how
dare you save Jeffrey Dean
Morgan oh damn he feels betrayed he going to
be mad at him holy [__] you're welcome that's
definitely uh an interesting way to wake up is
this that CGI I thought the same thing I was
like this CG Rock right now well the last time
I saw bad CGI like like that with the rock makes
me think of The Mummy Returns Scorpion King I
remember in the I mean it's not that bad but I
remember no I think it's just the the cam it's
a weird angle I just remember in the theater
seeing The Mummy Returns which I still enjoy that
film even though the first one was better but I
remember when the CGI Rock him I was like oh my
God I mean it's better than I could do and I'm
not a visual effects guy but damn that is yeah
you notice bad CG that is not very good luckily
for the most part the movie CGI has been pretty oh
no this this movie The CGI has been very good so
far it's just that one was a little bit noticeable
where's the body he's escaped he wants retribution
on you you didn't take him down he's got a healing
Factor he's wounded but he survived tracks aheed
Northeast wants DOD figures out your animal
survived that crash they going to have questions
for you too thank you for getting this old cowboy
off that plane well leave an [__] deserve a
second chance like my grandpappy always said those
[__] got to stick together Jeffrey Dean Morgan
is so Charming he really is you should be in more
movies the gorilla survived the crash the gorilla
doesn't concern me it'll respond to the radio
frequency and come straight to us you I saw
Michael Jordan jersey in there too I wouldn't be
surprised they're very rich FBI this is a warrant
for a complete search of your company's records
starting with your lab follow me it's so F how
panicked he is about going to jail you guys rather
going to die or go to prison for a long time I'm
I'm leaning on the dying one we horrified that was
happening out there originated in this lab we need
access to everything something tells me they're
going to tamper with it and give them something
or if this movie is really bold they they take
the serum themselves and they fight we're going
through the files of the scientist responsible
for these creatures Dr Kate Caldwell were just now
uncovering all the horrible things she was doing
during her time here oh are they trying to pin
it on Caldwell that's what it looks like smart I
mean shitty but smart what do we do now I'm sorry
doc there's no we anymore you lied to me after
one conversation scene I am sorry I lied to you
wanted something you lied to get it you're human
what makes you dislike people so much I fought in
Wars all over the world I got to see how people
really are you know where I found George he was
hiding underneath the poacher's truck backstory
when my team arrived these were in the middle of
butchering his mother oh they were cutting off her
hands so they could sell them as asrg George never
would have survived on his own I'll buy an all
like that on the black Market's worth of Fortune
so I took him with me and what happened to the
poachers well they shot at us and they missed
I laid the smackdown on them after college I was
using crisper to help endangered species in the
Arctic then my brother got sick doctors told him
he didn't have much of a chance but I knew crisper
could save P wiid showed up she made me her lead
genetic researcher but what I didn't know is that
every time I'd make a breakthrough that could
help my brother they were secretly using it to
build weaponized DNA okay I tried to destroy it
security just got to me before I could finish
the job oh man a month after I went to prison my
brother died damn they did that to her now they're
trying to pin this whole thing on her too oh I
just want to make sure can't hurt great anything
ever her life is fun also they're wonderful people
too as we mentioned many times sounds like a plan
sounds like a plan it's okay that you'll lie to
me in the beginning now we we understand each
other this film is actually really entertaining
it's fun yeah it's fun get in position to box
the out and moving fast oh George is with the
wolf you've engaged as a gorilla sir got them
surrounded in a quarry about 30 Mi outside
Chicago Al said to that one in the water is
going to at some point join forces two different
species making a coordinated longdistance Journey
that just doesn't happen is David shako he's a
primatologist these two know more about these
creatures than anyone on this planet I think
you need to hear what they have to say this
reminds me of Godzilla '98 where they brought
in Matthew brri they needed his expertise a
wolf and a gorilla would be attacking each other
they wouldn't be traveling in a straight line to
the same destination why are they going to
Chicago because they're being called enery
must be emitting some kind of signal to draw
them there those creatures will do anything
to get to that signal and make it stop Colonel
you have to evacuate Chicago H that should be
easy the FBI has requested that you remain here
these gentlemen will see you after making a big
mistake colel well if they listen to them we won't
have a third act true right yeah where's the fun
in that why would you listen to smart people who
does that I'm a former team guy let's not do this
thing where you get in my face you threaten me
because I'm going to have to knock you out I'm
going to choke you out so bad you're going to
urinate yourselves let's go oh hey he gave them
foreshadowing this is exactly
what I didn't want to happen
sleep so what are we looking for well we're
looking for a helicopter but preferably one
that SS surounded by military personel they
probably have a grounded medac Chopper at the
hospital that's why you always bring a doctor
they didn't take the clothes they didn't do
that that Trope The Rock would was going
to say I don't know if he's going to fit I
don't know he's going to fit he probably like
way stronger in like rip it yeah exactly well
well look at here stealing the hospital warberg
he's going to let them go I feel like we must
have an antidote at enene that can halt the
mutations you know if we get our hands on it
could be our only shot to stop George and the
Wolf before they level Chicago throw her them
the keys to they don't just leave keys under the
visor it's like this isn't Terminator 2 Judgment
Day we're on the same page when it comes to
widens they think they're Above the Law and
I want to remind them that they ain't really
like this character he's so fun I love this guy
clear fire like that we talk about the ah I don't
think that probably did anything I say again we
no oo oh nothing's working Captain Evans
what happens when you underestimate your
opponent I want ground artillery rolling
into downtown Chicago ASAP it's time we
throw everything we can at these things
and get people the hell out of that City
yeah they are evacuate Chicago I do love that
they're teaming up with him that's cool they're
never going to get everyone out of the city
in time you think do you know how many days
that would [Music] take third act here we
come also too we got the Waterfront so we
know that other creature is coming too so we
got three we got three creatures three creates
I'm hoping two of them don't survive though
the water one and the Wolf and George gets to
survive fingers crossed hope they all survive
you mean cuz they're unfortunate circumstances
for all of them I'm just saying if it
comes down to that that's what I would
hope messing stuff up you clear if
I remember the poster correctly I
thought George would be a lot bigger
oh I do remember doing that in in the
Rampage video game like with
the military damn oh my god
oh that I'm not going to lie that was sick where's
warthog one inbound sir warthog
one you are cleared out Rog it
that whoa slick move [Music] George oh
is that the water creature oh definitely
is that a shield it's underwater sir
we don't have any subs in the area H
oh I can't wait for the reveal what
it looks like damn it's going to be
humongous May is there's something big in
the river it is say the no has it go on
land wa oh it's a turtle is it it's a
turtle alligator crocodile I can't say
I crocod turle alligator whoa all forces
of that thing now enemy contact holy there a gator
oh
oh that thing's clearly the biggest out of all of
them why would you get so low and so close woof I
would do that from a distance right ooh they can't
stop them we got to get that antidote I thought
he was going to say but I can in a different movie
maybe yeah he dropped that bomb no not only do you
wipe out half a city but you destroy any evidence
and I need you to drop the cowboy [__] and get
with the program we just can't stand leaving our
friends behind get your ass out of here it's like
I can't take the bureaucracy here where two 85th
floor lab's in here damn it it's okay I'm strong
I'm going to break this down webs 30 minutes
out give a take just want to take out five city
blocks you better move I'm never taking your call
again what'd he say uh something about the mother
of all bond is on its way and we need to hurry
see everything in the lab is on one system but
there's a back door into the server so we should
be able to access every file I was thinking the
same thing oh totally we have visitors they erased
everything connected to the project but it's
here sometimes brains is better than
bronze oh yeah it's like one of those samples
from the beginning right is that The Cure not
a cure exactly R 19 doesn't revert them
to their normal size it just overrides
their unchecked aggression nice to see you Kate
good hell Claire now why don't you hand those
over let's go that's not happening oh
oh now let's go it's okay he'll be back
oh yeah she didn't kill him for some
reason well I I think she figured he
was probably but clearly he knows how
to sell being dead yes like the game
get it to the top it's a race now get
in unless you want to end up like your
friend Oh Boy George is really
big
wa oh man of course of course he was going to die
just a flesh wound m a flesh wound yeah I thought
you were dead well I think she missed all the
vital organs but uh don't jinx it now let's get
that an come on sa us wait he's fine I have one
for George we give it to George and maybe he can
help us stop the other two you know I'm actually
glad you're both still alive now you can go up
there and distract your friend while I get the
hell out of here that's not going to happen yeah n
George what the hell are you doing what beating
the monster to the gorilla o that was for my
brother yo he going to eat her he's going to
eat her yo that's crazy tastes like rich food
to me knew she's going to die who the hell
are you I'm the fell that was going to run
up those stairs to arrest you but sh his worst
fears going to jail going to jail I'm actually
glad I was wrong on that front that he's going
to jail you got a laptop in that bag there you
give it to me and you can just get right out
that door okay this wasn't even my idea oh
God drop on him yep I had a
feeling yeah y that was a lot oh
God oh my God
God this puts Man of Steel to shame I was
just thinking that in my head but I didn't
want to say it because I'm sure the people have
said too many comic book references from Andrew
already how the hell did we get out this
roof we're going to jump cuz I'm the Rock
and I can still withstand it maybe we don't
have to get off the roof at all what oh are
they going to ride on George's back off
the roof what you do if you want to fly
we not going to fly we're going to crash
we just need to get enough lift to stay
on top of the building as it falls you know
just like riding an avalanche I'm so um okay
what oh my God this could get ugly oh my God
just think of it as a really
dangerous roller coaster ride
oh
who oh my God I would just pass out from my
stomach [Music] dropping just hover enough for it
to land on the building that's Fallen got to give
him points for creativity yeah George you okay my
buddy his friend he's back thank God we really
going to keep you out buddy I know but that nuke
is on its way right now oh I look like [__] yep
that that means [Music] [__] stop him George get
him escorts are in position we are 8 minutes
from Target oh no I want you to take this humy
and find a sa bone and get a hold of r he's our
only shot at calling off this air strike he's the
only way we got to stop these things before they
destroy the city that's right let's kick some ass
should have said let's lay the smackdown on their
candy [Music] asses like how dare you betray us oh
[__] oh let's
go
Rock like I'll just watch George [Music]
oh hey come and get me you ugly son of a
[__] hide inside the building oh
oh nice nice oh oh ooh that was completely on
accident but we'll take it a win is a win oh
oh a win is a win win is a win one to go
tell me what you're doing here the anote
worked Davis and George are trying to stop
the other two but there's still civilians and
Military on the ground we have to call off
the air strike were they going to listen to
him rock is like George I could really use your
help get him George yeah beat him with that
truck me a favor would you and take a Gand
Federal Plaza before you drop them break
up the Drone feed on Federal Plaza it's me
driving oh oh damn dude
George is in it to win it all
right no
nice oh that'll get him that'll kill him
wa well
done the Rock wins oh oh it does have a healing
Factor nice job George
oh George buddy God I think it'll be okay
hopefully oh buddy come on take
it out take it out up you got to
move oh [Music]
no are the key still inside on
this one oh okay I guess they
are oh
no oh you mess with my friend you mess with me
mother I wonder what he was going
to say before they cut out no idea
couldn't couldn't even give you a
single guess just have to imagine
yeah [__] mother friend killer yeah
something like that yeah probably that
one is the building going to collapse on it I
don't think that's going to do anything George
is going to get him yes yes use that stick
ooh right in the head right in the eye woo
[Music] yeah there we go yeah that
will uh that'll do it that'll get
him I think George has had a lot
of uh injuries sustained aboard
me oh No George hey buddy don't die
George save the city yeah you save
me that's right that's friendship that's how we
do oh George George I'm so sorry Davis saved my
life he saved a lot of people's
lives he saved his too earlier
damn so all those people would have been
nuked George is a hero yes he did oh
George did I just see you close your eye I just
saw you open your eye yeah George son of a [__]
pretending to be dead you did that earlier no no
no no no it's not funny and I wasn't crying we're
friends right yeah oh God that I like George's
sense of humor yeah thanks for calling off the
air strike the wise cat War once said [__] got
to stick together then find George here in new
home where are we going to put him New York where
would you put him I guess in a jungle somewhere I
don't know h a liting people down from the build
I like seeing the scope of that from far off that
looks cool oh my gosh yeah Rampage thank you to
Shopify for sponsoring which is what we use for
our merch store and is our gamechanging partner
in Ecommerce so whether you're launching a passion
project or scaling to new heights Shopify is
e-commerce Powerhouse guiding you at every step
from creating your first online store to opening
physical locations Shopify makes it seamless it's
perfect whether you're selling exclusive merch or
unique collector thanks to their all-encompassing
platform for both online and inore sales their
checkout system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than other
platforms and let's not forget Shopify magic
the AI tool that elevates your business with
minimal effort but seriously reflecting on your
journey using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition smooth
growth exponential thank you again reject Nation
from simplifying sales to scaling our offerings
Shopify has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us it Powers 10%
of us e-commerce backing businesses big and small
in over 175 countries there a war-winning support
always there to guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a dollar
a month at shopify.com rejects all overc case
shopify.com rejects start your Shopify success
story now let's grow together with Shopify team
big thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this video
a real game changer I've been using for years
that's right years so whenever they want to work
with us it's an instant yes you've likely heard
about expressvpn for online privacy and security
but there's more to it than that however there
was a very real incident recently with Spectrum
Shing down my internet and contacting me due to
a suspecting hacking attempt and funny enough I
realized I hadn't actually activated my expressvpn
on my new laptop that I got a couple of months ago
so I was paying the consequences having faced a
serious hacking issue on YouTube a couple years
ago that made Express VPN my go-to for both
security and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this channel
knows you can use expressvpn to watch movies
and shows on Netflix that are not available
in your country this means accessing a vast
rate of content of over a 100 countries like
a global Cinema your fingertips it's super
easy open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it whether it's
kramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu BBC I player
YouTube or more expressvpn has you covered and
it's incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's versatile too
working on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere any screen
protect and elevate your internet experience so if
you want to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com reex and you can get
an extra 3 months of expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to expressvpn.com
reex to learn more thank you again that was
a rampage I mean look it wasn't like super
deep or anything but I mean I I I had fun it
was entertaining I mean it for what it was it
was fun and entertaining I think my favorite
part of the film besides obviously the third
act where we got all that action and rampaging
stuff happening uh that really reminded me of
the little bit I do remember from the video game
again it was a long time ago when I played it on
N64 though I do remember fighting the Army and
all that stuff uh the little bit I do remember
um which again visually speaking I do I thought
that was pretty cool stuff um I did you know
the the emotional stuff between um George and
Davis the Rocks character right uh I actually
did appreciate that I know we didn't really
go super deep into the backstory there with
but like the little bit of of the flashback there
with the exposition from The Rock saying how you
know that poachers were there to uh that took
apart his mother and all that and then the rock
saved him and that's what their their connection
between them was like I actually like I I got the
feels from that a little bit um and you know it
made sense in in the world why they are so close
and bonded and connected with each other and you
know explained their whole relationship and I I
actually appreciate that was my favorite part
of the the entire film on top of the third Act
of course like I just mentioned but um what you
think of the film I thought this was the epitome
of a summer blockbuster like it wasn't trying to
be more than what it was it wasn't trying to be
this super deep story or trying to break the mold
in any capacity but it was a lot of fun you know
I thought the relationship between George and
Davis was something that was you know I think
the rock really made that relationship what it
was and like the way that they animated the uh
George himself was really cool I thought the CGI
for the most part was not again not groundbreaking
like not like Avatar levels but like it was
really good for like what it was you know it
was savatar level ground oh my mind was blown the
entire time it was good though no it was good and
I thought even the the alligator and the uh the
wolf like that looked good and even the rat at the
beginning uh and I really did actually appreciate
to not revealing the alligator or C whatever that
was I I appreciate that they kind of went the
Jaws approach not revealing it toward the end
there um but yeah I mean like I said this was fun
it was schlocky it was entertaining and like you
said not super deep or anything and then I also
I I don't care how how cartoonish and ridiculous
they were I I like the villains in this they
were dumb it yeah and when I say I like them
I mean obviously you know they're awful people I
you know I wasn't rooting for them or anything I
I clearly wanted them you know their lives to be
ended the way it did I thought that was perfectly
characterized even though I I was like why are you
guys waiting so long to get out of here when you
know they're clearly coming and all that um but
um I just thought it was just so cartoonish it
was hysterical that I actually appreciate it and
for this type of film I just I don't know I just
thought it was fine the way it was portrayed the
way their characters were portrayed by those two
actors um but yeah I actually uh enjoyed it and
also too um I liked uh the characterization in
the storyline we got for Naomi Harris's character
although I thought it was kind of uh again not
looking super deep into it or anything I thought
it was like we were like was there a scene scene
when she's like you lied to me and like you know
because she just came into the uh into the the
wildlife zoo or wherever that he worked and she
just said hey I'm I'm here like is he getting
bigger and like there wasn't really much dialogue
between them and then like literally crap just
went crazy after a few seconds and then they were
chasing George and then then they got you know on
the plane and all that it's like you guys really
don't know really there could have been more to
establish their relationship like you're not
going to film school to watch this movie you
to the theater to watch it taking your family
taking the teens you know I'm sure this would
have been great in 3D but yeah it was a lot of fun
also Jeffrey Dean Morgan killed it he was amazing
in this great bringing that charm that he always
brings I feel like he just walked off the set of
walking dead because he's just so charming and
so so oozing with Charisma when he's out playing
neegan so yeah just I thought he was great uh
like you said the villains like kind of cartoony
like kind of you know they were exactly what they
needed to be for for this type of film yeah and
even though he was uh Charming like At first I was
like I'm not GNA like even though I'm GNA like his
performance Charming wise Jeffrey Dean Morgan but
I'm not going to like this character I like the
way he ended up developing and then there was a
connection between him and uh the Rock and Naomi
Harris and like okay there's a rapport and then
they're going to work together especially after uh
they saved him and then okay I understand like I
actually too need you guys if we're going to like
help each other in in this type of situation like
I'm clearly out of my depths here cuz you know he
he thought that George he had George under control
with sleeping and then okay again I'm clearly out
of my depths I I I really do need you guys here
for this situation um so I actually thought that
was you know very uh you know organic in terms
of the way that they all start to work together
so I appreciate that and again a good good little
development for his character in terms of working
with the rock and aom Harris but uh yeah I mean
uh I I like I said for this type film I thought
it was fun it was entertaining I think you summed
it up best it's a fun summer blockbuster it's one
of those you know like a like a fast and furious
type of just turn your brain off have a good time
summer blockbuster film if you you look at it any
differently it might not be for you right and I
don't know what this movie made box office wise
cuz I I was aware of it when it came out but I
didn't go to the the theater to see it but I will
say I respect the movie for one knowing what it
is and two being this one-off experience you know
we don't need a rampage two or Rampage Three like
Miss the days of just like a movie just standing
on its own and being this experiened and like who
knows I think it leaves room for the imagination
to see like what the the relationship Becomes of
between na onlyi Harris's character in The Rock or
what BEC comes what comes of the new Dynamic with
him being so big and I guess permanently staying
that way between George and Davis so yeah man I
don't I don't think I need another one I don't
know what the premise of another one would be
I feel like it probably be contrived if they try
to do that but well you don't need Rampage 2 but
I need Rampage 2 need him to fight need him to go
to space fight other big monsters I was actually
surprised there wasn't more monsters in the movie
the fact that there's only three big big guys I
was like okay I mean probably like budget wise are
like we can afford three we can we'll limit it to
three guys I thought the George was going to be
bigger but you know I thought it was it wasun I
was yeah I was you know what with the scope of
the film and I don't know what the budget was
like I thought three was fine and like what all
the Rampage and destruction even though it kind
of happened pretty quickly uh that third act
I was fine with three I mean I think it would
have been a bit much with especially with I mean
whatever it was like an hour and 40 minutes I was
okay with three if they would have had more I
mean fine but it was easy to follow with three
um so I agree but uh yeah overall fun film uh
and I enjoyed as always I enjoyed uh Dwayne
The Rock Johnson he was he's entertaining as as
as always I mean he's it's always fun to watch
a film with the rock so what would you rate it
oh out of 10 um uh I'd probably give this one
like a seven out of 10 or something like a 6.5
7 out of 10 I think I'm right around there too F
6.5 to seven yeah it was a lot of fun guys this a
good time but we want to know what you guys would
R it yeah let us know what you guys think let us
know in the comments sound off did you enjoy the
reaction did you like the movie itself what was
your favorite part of the movie let us know and
let us know if you want us to do San Andreas
know the director and The Rock did that film
as well we're down for some more rockage in our
life yes sir all right you guys thank you so much
for watching it's been a pleasure and I hope you
have a beautiful rest of your day bye [Music] guys